[Music] We
condemn all the teachers of the independence movement.
[Music] They
say it is over with the announcement, but
this is invalid both legally and in terms of public sentiment. We
will not stop marching vigorously until it is done. Thank you.
[Music]
Only on the premise of this agreement.  It is
so unfortunate that there was no such story. The
Yoon Seok-yeol government is taking a hard line against the rise of a new type of pro-Japanese state in the country that
tramples on the confirmed achievements of its citizens and
imposes legal responsibility on Japanese war criminal companies. It is an
unacceptable
tyrant.
This solution is between Korea and Japan.
I hope that this will be a window of opportunity for a new history for both countries to move beyond antagonism and conflict and into the future. And I
think this is the last chance.
[Music]